- I have to say again it
was great to sing your music
last week at the Academy
of Country Music Awards.
But I will say it's always, always, always
going to be terrifying to sing your song
in front of you while you're there.
Just so you know, I'm
always sweating profusely.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh, well, I mean
I don't think you have to
worry with a voice like yours.
I was so honored
(audience cheering)
and nobody can sing like you.
So I was very proud of of you
and so proud of your rendition of it.
It's great.
One of the best ever, ever, ever.
- You are so kind.
(audience cheering)
And it was also
we haven't really been
able to talk about it
but it was cool to sing "9 to 5"
We did the kind of reimagined version
of "9 to 5" for your documentary
still working "9 to 5", which is amazing.
Not just the song, but the
documentary is amazing.
So thank you for letting
me be a part of that.
I got to brag to Blake
Shelton about that moment.
(kelly laughs)
- Well, you did a great job on that too.
I love how you took that
and just made it your own.
And I got a chance to sing
background for a change
but I'm really proud of
that rendition of it.
And I think hopefully
it'll do well for us.
It's great in the documentary.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my God.
It's a really cool thing.
James, do you have a favorite Dolly song?
- Yeah, well, first of all
off of the new album, "Run Rose Run."
I love "Big Dreams And Faded Jeans"
and "Woman Up (And Take It Like A Man)".
Right?
- I love that one.
I love-
(kelly laughing)
- Yeah.
He has always loved that one.
- "My Life Would Suck Without
You", I love that one.
- Yes.
- Yes Kelly.
- James Patterson knows our music.
(audience cheering)